so first off
uh thank you so much for coming to check
out this talk
i was a little worried no one would show
up because it does uh it is
the gloomiest sounding title in the
world basically so thank you for coming
to check it out
hopefully none of you are depressed just
by thinking about this topic
anyways today we're gonna be talking
about something that i really enjoy
uh the 12 factors of pain and suffering
all right so just sit back relax we'll
have a good time
so first off i'll introduce myself i'm
randall i work at a company called octa
you haven't heard of us we're like a web
security company we do stuff around user
authentication user authorization oauth
open id connect stuff like that if you
want to see some of my
more cyber security focus talks you can
just look them up online
and a little bit about my background so
primarily i'm a python javascript and
golang developer
i got started coding when i was 11 or 12
somewhere around there
so it's been quite a while i'm getting
old now i've been doing open source
for a very long time so i run a lot of
open source projects
i contribute to a lot of open source
projects and for the last seven years or
so
most of the open source work i've done
has been around making the internet
safer so building tools for developers
to
you know handle authentication
authorization uh cryptography
and make it easier i'm also an author so
i've written tons of technical articles
and things like that but most
importantly i consider myself a builder
and what i mean by that is that ever
since i was a kid i've had the
the great fortune to have built a number
of different applications everything
from really tiny command line apps
that basically only i used to really
massive api services with billions of
requests per
day and one of the things that's
somewhat unique about my experience is
that for the most part
i've never really worked with other
programmers like most of my career
building applications working at
companies and just doing side projects
i've always been building things solo
for the most part
and so because of that i sort of
developed my own set of best practices
for web development over all the years
and that's why six or seven years ago i
was really excited to stumble across
something called
the 12 factor app now raise your hand in
here if any of you have heard
of the 12 factor app there's a couple
people
cool now raise your hand if any of you
are web developers because this is going
to be very relevant to you
all right a lot more people so if you're
not familiar with it
the 12 factor app is essentially a set
of principles and what they define
is how to build really simple scalable
and dependable
web applications that's really what they
talk about it's a really nice system
now instead of me just sort of going
through each one of the 12 and
explaining what it is and how it works
because everyone hates that right it's
pretty boring
i thought instead i would just explain
all the ways that i [ __ ] them up
because i don't know about you guys but
i've been programming for about 19 years
now and i [ __ ] stuff up every single day
so i'm sure you all do as well and no
one wants to hear the good stories
people just want to hear the bad stories
right like the dirt the drama
that's why reality tv is so popular so
that's what we're gonna do today
i'm gonna air some of my dirty laundry
and it's you know this talk isn't really
for you it's more for me to just get
this off my chest so it's a form of
therapy
so anyways let's get right into it the
first factor
in the 12 factor application is all
about managing your code base now it
sounds
super simple right you have a code base
and maybe you deploy it
so you have a project and you deploy
that project into different environments
you have production
staging development one development two
whatever you have all these environments
and this makes
perfect sense to all of you i am sure
now you might be wondering how i screwed
this up so i'll tell you the entire
story
so going back quite a few years maybe i
want to say 10
11 years ago or something like that it's
been a while now i was working for this
company
i dropped out of college and i was
working for this company and i was
working around the clock i was trying to
prove myself as a developer and the
first big project i worked on
was this massive website it was tnid.us
at the time
and basically what we did is whenever
someone googled a phone number a
us-based phone number like this this is
my cell phone number by the way
so don't like call me during the
presentation or it's going to mess stuff
up
but what would happen is whenever
someone googled it we were the first
result and so people would find our
website they'd land on our website and
then we would show them all sorts of
information
like the person's name who owns that
phone number their their
approximate address a bunch of metadata
and this was fantastic because guess
what a lot of people google phone
numbers when they miss a phone call
millions of people a day actually and so
this website was like printing money for
us at the time
and the reason is that we would make ten
dollars in an affiliate commission
every time someone would land on the
site and purchase an additional report
where they could find more information
about this phone number
so it's fantastic so as i mentioned this
was my first big job out of college i
was working crazy hours all the time
and my wife really hated that so she was
like hey look you've been working 16
hours a day for like two years
let's go on vacation so we scheduled our
very first vacation trip we went to
santa cruz in california which is sort
of where i'm from
we have this nice beach house and as
soon as i get to the beach house no
joke i get a phone call from my boss and
he said hey
uh you know we have a little bit of a
problem i was like all right what's
going on
he said well our website uh has no users
on it which is
extremely uh not ordinary so i checked
it out and basically this is what
happened
google banned us from the index so they
de-indexed our site
and this happened in february of 2010 i
think
when google rolled out their panda
search algorithm update it was a really
big deal it banned a lot of sites
that had certain criteria like ours and
at the time
no one knew what was going on i didn't
know what was going on so what i did
is i opened a support ticket with google
and i assumed that
you know there was some mistake and they
would eventually unban me but then i
also thought well
if it takes a while for google support
to get back to me i better
launch another site so we can start
monetizing that site so what i did
is i copy and pasted my hook my code
base i bought a new sketchy domain name
and i spent six to eight hours redoing
the site so it matched the new domain
name
like i changed the the the logo the
header the images the colors i wanted to
make it feel like a different brand
so i probably spent you know six to
eight hours on that
now over the next couple days this new
website got indexed by google
we started to get a lot of users coming
into it we started making money again
and everyone for the most part is pretty
happy
but about a week later this site got
banned as well
and so i thought you know the first site
getting banned was a fluke the second
site getting banned
something weird is going on so what did
i do well i just copy and pasted the
code base twice more
i bought two new domain names and i spun
that [ __ ] up so i spent you know a good
16 hours on these next two
and again same thing happened so launch
the website it's going pretty good
start making money again and then banned
about a week later
so at this point i'm starting to panic
because this website was generating
millions of dollars it was a big deal
it was making a lot of people money and
i you know i like money so i was
freaking out a bit
so what i did is i just went on a copy
paste rampage
i don't know if any of you have ever
done this i am certainly guilty of it
so i copy and pasted the [ __ ] out of
this code base and i spent the next i
don't know i want to say
four to five months maybe something like
that playing this constant cat and mouse
game with google
of trying to launch these new really
spammy websites designed to drive
affiliate sales
and in the end it didn't work out but
coming back and thinking about this
experience
this whole process was just brutal and
the reason it was so brutal
is because what i should have done is if
i was gonna do this the right way
i would have variablized and templatized
my one code base because the problem
that i had here wasn't that i just had
to launch all these new websites
the problem was that i wasn't smart
about it i was just in you know it's
constantly stressed state i was going in
there
whenever i added a new feature i would
literally go into all of these code
bases 20 30 code bases
and start copying and pasting code
around as [ __ ] a nightmare obviously
so anyways the lesson learned here is
don't do this it's terrible
all right next up the next factor in the
12-factor application
is all about dependency management now
this is also one of those topics
sounds pretty straightforward right you
have dependencies and you need to
declare and isolate them so how does
this work
well when you're building an application
today the first thing you do is you
declare all your dependencies right so
maybe if you're building a node
application
you have some javascript dependencies
you define somewhere in a package.json
file or something like that
but you list it up the next thing you do
is you isolate those dependencies
so you're gonna take it uh maybe you
install all the dependencies using npm
or whatever
package manager uh you're using and
that's going to take all your
dependencies install them into this nice
little environment
so you can run your project makes
perfect sense
now the way i mess this one up is a
little more complicated
so this happened approximately seven
years ago i was working on a fun project
on my free time
it was this image optimization api now
the concept for this
is is pretty simple you're a developer
and you have an image
that you would really like to optimize
oh it's not coming through very well but
it is a really cool picture
of a crow holding a knife all right you
have to trust me on this
now you want to optimize the image so
what you do is you send it to the api
service
it is going to optimize the image and
then send it back to you
and the way that it worked the way that
it was able to reduce file size was
you know basically i had a vps server
running i
believe it's on some shared web host and
i went out and i installed all these
really popular linux command line tools
uh there's something here opti png jpeg
optim gift sickle these are some popular
command line tools you can use to
optimize images based on the file format
and so the api surface was pretty slick
whenever developers sent an image
to my service i would basically you know
look at the type of image they sent me
if it was a png
my application would just shell out to
the command line and run the opt png
tool to compress the image
take the resulting image and send it
back and so forth and so on
now this service was working flawlessly
i launched it i put it on a subreddit it
got sort of popular
had a lot of people using it and i just
didn't really think about it for a few
months
well after a while maybe five six months
something like that i get a bunch of
alerts from my hosting provider
basically saying hey
you're throwing off a few 500s you
should look into it so i go back and i
look into and i realize well my service
is doing great it just can't handle the
amount of requests that it's getting
so i decided all right i'm going to
scale this thing up so what i did
i spun up a second server copied my code
base over
you know ran the npm install this was
built in an early version of node at the
time
got it all working i it was you know all
these web servers were behind a load
balancer so i fired off a single request
to the api to test it out it worked
so i went to sleep and the next morning
i woke up
and there was a ton of error messages
all right and
basically the gist of it was that the
load balancer had routed my test request
to the first server that was working
and not the new server i provisioned and
the reason it wasn't working is because
i forgot to install
all of these command line tools on there
right
like this is one of the things about
dependency management that can sometimes
be tricky
you know we often as developers think
about dependency management as like
your javascript dependencies your python
dependencies but a lot of the time
dependencies are a more holistic thing
you know it's anything your application
requires to function like command line
tools for example
so this is how i learned the lesson
about dependency management
all right next let's talk about storing
configuration data
in 12 factor apps what you want to do is
you always want to store configuration
data for your application in environment
variables
i'm sure you've seen this quite a quite
a bit if you're a web developer you
might need to store a database url or
some api keys
the amount of threads you're going to
run in things like that as part of your
application's configuration
and in 12 factor apps you ideally want
to package all these things up
and stick them in environment variables
because it's a uniform interface
that any application can work with
regardless of where those variables are
stored
so today there's a lot of tools like aws
parameter store
there's vault from hashicorp all sorts
of cool tools that make this easier
now back in the day after i dropped out
of school i was doing a lot of telephony
work so i got involved in the telephony
programming industry
and most of the software that i wrote
back then was based around this open
source phone system called asterisk
if you haven't heard of it it's a really
cool program it lets you automate things
like phone calls
sms messages you know anything telephony
related
and when i started working at this
company doing telephony work
the project was still co-located on
physical hardware this was a long time
ago before cloud providers had really
like taken off and one of the first
things i wanted to do was like move this
into the cloud so i could dynamically
scale it and make everything really nice
and clean
so what i did is i set up a test account
with rackspace which was a really big
cloud provider at the time
and in order for me to start
automatically scaling my code i had to
you know interact with rackspace
automatically create and provision
servers
do all this stuff right so i went and
created a rackspace api key
now uh also i should mention that my
code was hosted on github
just like this and so what i did is in
the
the sense of urgency where i was trying
to get things working really quick i
just went ahead and cheated and i
copied my api key i just hard coded it
straight into my code base on github
now you all might laugh and say wow this
guy's a total new but back then
github bots like weren't a real thing so
i wasn't i was quite surprised the next
day when i woke up
and someone had basically ran a github
bot to look for noobs publishing their
api credentials like me
uh grabbed my api key off of github and
then immediately started making requests
to rackspace
creating really large instances and
running tor exit nodes
which used a lot of resources if you
aren't familiar so
when i woke up in the morning the first
thing i thought was i had this massive
wall of emails and i just thought [ __ ]
uh and it had nothing to do with work it
turns out rackspace
their sales team reached out to me and
basically said hey we
we can see you really love using
rackspace you just signed up you've
already spent 25 000
which is about 23 000 euros i believe uh
which is a lot of money and i was a
total broke i was completely broke i
didn't even have a credit card that
would accept a 25 000
bill uh thankfully rackspace was super
amazing so they cancelled it out they
said don't worry about it
noobs like you happen all the time to us
which is very which is very
kind of them um but the lesson learned
here is don't cheat
like i was just really trying to get
stuff out fast and i said ah screw it
it's just a test account anyways it's
not a big deal but
bad things can happen when you're not
careful so don't don't be an idiot like
i am
all right next let's talk about backing
services so in 12
factor apps you always want to treat
your backing services
as attachable and detachable resources
now i realize that sounds sort of
confusing when i say it out loud to
myself i think wow there's a lot of
buzzwords in there but
let me explain how this works so you
have your application running in
production somewhere
right and that application probably
relies on a lot of
backing services right like maybe if
your app is sending emails
you have an smtp service that you need
to work with maybe if your app is
storing files
you're you know using amazon s3 bucket
to store files
maybe if your app is using a database
like postgres you have a database url
that you need to worry about
and the idea here on backing services is
you want to treat these things as
attachable and detachable resources like
you should easily be able
to switch out the database that your app
is using you shouldn't need to update
code for that to happen
all you should need to do is be able to
update some configuration
otherwise there's going to be a night
where when you need to change
infrastructure around in the future
so how did i screw this up well this is
actually a picture i drew myself i don't
know if you can tell because it's so
quality
but uh this is me as a young developer
when i was probably 12 years old or so
and when i started programming i like
immediately fell in love like i went to
the library i got all the books on it i
was
just working in my room constantly and i
was a super introverted
nerdy little kid i never had any like
you know outside friends basically
and so this fit me very well and like a
lot of
young programmers who are total noobs
like me i thought
all right i need to make a blog because
i'm doing some cool [ __ ] and the whole
world needs to know about it
and i built this blog and it was
terrible quality as you can imagine i
had a shared web host
and that web host was running my sequel
on localhost with no username or
password as one of those you know cheap
rental hosts
and i built my website on here in php
over the course of many years i worked
on this project all the way up through
school and everything
now when i first got to university i
still
was a really nerdy introverted kid that
had no friends but was like pretty good
at programming at that point
and so i thought to myself i thought to
myself all right well
how are you going to make friends you
got to have a strategy here and so
the best thing i could think of was i
should just give out free pirated movies
to everyone
because everyone loves free [ __ ] that's
a fact and at the time
netflix didn't exist like the online
version of netflix we just had the
you know the dvds in the mail situation
and so what i did is i signed up for
netflix in the states
and i subscribed to their four movies a
month plan or four movies a week plan so
what they would do is every week
they would mail me out a bunch of cds
with movies on them and i would take
those
i'd rip them to avi files and i'd upload
them onto my website
then whenever i met friends at school i
would say hey you know it's nice to meet
you just fyi
if you want to check out some movies
like here's my personal site it has a
bunch of [ __ ] just
feel free to use it and it worked i made
a lot of friends it was awesome it was
super cool so if you're looking to make
friends in school like i highly
recommend this approach now this went
really great for me i did make friends
until one day i was doing this and i ran
out of disk space
which you could obviously imagine is
absolutely going to happen
so what did i do well i thought to
myself
randall you've done it you've built a
successful service that people enjoy
using
congratulations now it's time for you to
make amends for all this terrible code
that you've created
so you know this project had amassed
over over time over
six years or however long i was working
on it it had transformed from a few php
files to like hundreds of php files and
thousands maybe even
tens of thousands of lines of code it
was just an absolute
disaster so what i did is i said okay
first thing i'm going to do to clean
this up
i'm going to migrate the mysql database
to a separate host i'm going to make
this really nice and clean
so i set up a new my sql server copied
all the data over into it
and then i went back to update my code
base to start talking to the new
database and that's when i ran into a
bunch of problems
now the problems i ran into were
basically that in this code
i had always assumed that mysql would be
available on localhost
and that it would have no username and
password and if you've ever written php
code you've probably seen a line of code
that says mysql underscore connect well
i had that sprinkled throughout hundreds
of files multiple times within each file
and so what i quickly came to realize is
that it wasn't that easy to actually
update this database and had i known
about the 12-factor app design
principles when this happened when i was
you know learning these things
originally
i don't think i would have made this
mistake because i would have you know
gone in there
had a single environment variable
pointing to my database that i could
have updated to localhost or to remote
host or whatever it was
and that way i wouldn't have had to
spend you know tons of time in the
middle of school with finals you know
working on stuff as a matter of fact
maybe that would have helped me not drop
out of school
i'm not sure but it might have helped
all right next up let's talk about the
build release and run factor
so the rule here is you always want to
separate these stages in your
application life cycle
out so when you're building a project
you're writing code right you're in
development mode
now at some point you're going to write
some code that builds your project so
you have a build pipeline of some sort
so if you're
using java maybe you can pile your stuff
into byte code before sending it off to
the jvm or whatever
you know java developers do i guess uh
you're gonna have some
configuration data these would be all
the environment variables api keys all
that stuff your application uses
and then you have a release and what's
really important to think about here
is these are separate stages you write
code you build it
you take the build you merge it with
some configuration data
and this creates a release of some sort
now you can call us a release artifact
you can call whatever you want
but the release is actually the thing
it's the mix of the build in the config
that you would deploy
and test and do stuff like that against
now the way i screwed this up
is you know i sort of mentioned it
before but when i was a kid i was sort
of a script kitty
like i didn't really know that much i
was just hacking around on things
this image doesn't look too great but
it's from the movie hackers my favorite
movie of all time
and basically the way i would write web
code back in these days is i was in my
room and i had a desktop computer
and i also had that shared web host that
i told you about earlier so when i would
write code essentially what i would do
is i'd write code then i would copy the
code using scp
onto my web server then i would just go
and refresh the browser
and test the code out because a lot of
php code pretty simple
and if you've ever done this before you
will quickly realize how
slow this is like you start just looking
at the bytes per second that are being
transferred from here it's terrible
and so i would get really impatient what
i would do is i would just ssh straight
into the host as root
i would just edit the code live on the
web server and test it out
now this this doesn't sound that bad to
me i know people are going to judge but
you know whatever
uh this was actually fantastic because
i'm testing things out quicker i
you know it felt pretty pretty great the
problem i ran into had nothing to do
with this the problem i ran into is that
i wasn't using version control and i
didn't know about version control
and so i was basically my own git
compiler in my head
so i would write some code here then i
would write some code on the web server
then i would try to keep these versions
of code together so like
if i got something working here then
i'll go and copy some files back here
but then maybe i'll write some code here
and copy the files back there
it just became very untenable and i was
extremely frustrated
and the reason i was so frustrated is
because i didn't keep all those stages
separate that we just talked about
if i had done that then i wouldn't have
uh you know been in this mess so anyways
that was my lesson learned there and
that's how that factor works
all right next up let's talk about
processes now
when uh you're building a 12-factor app
your app should really just be
one or more stateless processes that are
running with the keyword here being
stateless this is super important has to
be stateless
and the way that i screwed this up was i
was working this telephony company
and we were building this free
conference calling software
and it was very very exciting so it ran
in a data center
on these physical servers with pri lines
plugged into it
and basically we had a few of these
servers in iraq
and what we would do is when people
would call into this service we would
put them in a conference call for free
and we had different conference phone
numbers that were routed to different
servers
now everything was fine here and one of
the cool features of our service that
distinguished us from all of our
competitors was this
we allowed people to call in who created
a conference line and customize all of
their voice prompts
so they could call in they could
customize their voice prompts and
whenever they did this what would happen
is we would just store those voice
recordings on the server
in which they called into now this
worked totally fine for a while
until one day of course one of the
servers went down
and so when the server went down i you
know i talked to the data center they
rerouted the
the conference numbers from here down to
here and i thought everything was going
to be totally fine
but the problem i realized later is that
well those voice recordings were only
here
this wasn't a collection of stateless
processes this was a collection of
stateful
processes they required all this you
know audio data state
and because i wasn't packaging that up
with the process itself
i was running into issues so i had to
make some really painful
emails and phone calls to users telling
them hey i know you spent a lot of money
hiring a professional voice actress to
record all these nice prompts but
they're all gone and you need to do it
over again so that was terrible
all right next let's talk about port
binding this one's really simple
uh you know this is true not only for
web apps but just a lot of services in
general nowadays but i think the
there's still a lot of truth in this but
whenever you're building an app a web
app you want to make sure that you
expose your apps via port binding
there's a lot of reasons for this but
the main idea boils down to this
you know if you're building if you have
a web server running somewhere
back in the old days what you do is you
would have your app bind itself to port
80 port
443 for tls things like that and
this has sort of always been like a bad
idea and the reason why
is that it really shackles you to your
infrastructure so if you're building a
web app and you're specifically telling
it to bind itself to one of these ports
it's generally not a good idea what you
should do instead
is have your routing infrastructure tell
your applications which ports to bind to
in a dynamic way so if you're using any
fancy platform as a service companies
today like heroku this is how they all
function behind the scenes you know they
run
really large instances and they map
inbound requests to
ports on your instance so you can have
hundreds or thousands of applications
running on a single
server and all this stuff is handled
really nicely
i don't have any sad story here because
this is the one thing that i haven't
screwed up
thank god all right next let's talk
about concurrency
so the in 12 factor apps when you get to
a point where you need concurrency you
always want to scale your applications
up
via the process model so what does this
mean well
basically every application as we talked
about is just a collection of processes
right
so maybe you have a single web process
that is handling incoming requests
and returning responses well if you're
building a 12-factor app what you want
to do is when you
run out of throughput here and you need
to add more capacity you should just be
able to add a second web process
and load balance incoming requests
between them
but applications have other types of
processes too right you might have
worker processes
processing items from a queue you might
need to scale that up and down
dynamically based on what's going on in
your application
there's all sorts of things you can do
so this is sort of how you want to scale
things
now the way that i screwed this one up
is again going back until i was about 15
years old
and i was working on this project that
to date was the
i think the coolest project that i ever
built it was something that like
i felt extremely passionately about i
thought it was going to be like the next
big thing i was super psyched
and basically it was just an irc web app
now if any of you haven't used irc
there's like an old chat room
style stuff when i was growing up i met
a lot of really awesome programmers on
irc and i learned a lot about
programming from it
but there wasn't a way to easily connect
to irc without basically
needing to be a programmer not that many
people understood like the software you
had to use to connect
so i started building a web app that
allowed people to connect to irc rooms
the way it worked is people go to the
web app then they could join all the
chat rooms they wanted
and then i started showing this
prototype that i built to a few friends
and they were psyched they were like oh
my god
this is amazing and they started using
it all the time and so i had that
positive feedback and i had that
momentum going and i was just like
so excited so i decided
that i should build this thing properly
so it can scale up and down because
managing a lot of persistent connections
like this is actually extremely
difficult
so what i did is at the time i was
building everything in c so i wrote this
entire thing in c which first of all
terrible idea for a website uh second of
all
i decided to go all in so instead of
using simple processes that i could
scale up and down like what we just
talked about
i decided to turn this thing into a
linux system daemon
now i'm not sure if you're familiar with
the concept of linux demons but
basically they register themselves
with your init system and they spawn off
lots of child processes and things like
that so basically whenever people join a
chat room
i'd spawn off a bunch of threads and i
would have to manage them
and do a lot of inter-process
communication all these relatively
complex things
now the problem i had is that while this
worked okay
um after my site started getting a
decent amount of usage i would run into
tons of issues so like a process would
be killed
and that process would like cascade
failure which would kill the demon which
would restart
and eventually when this happened like
everyone's chatroom connections would
drop and be reset
which is an incredibly bad user
experience and i would love to tell you
that this story has a positive outcome
but it doesn't
i worked on this for like six months
poured my heart and soul into it and i
can never
resolve these really complex issues that
i was having
with basically shared memory and memory
locking between these threads
and at the time i just wasn't
sophisticated enough to handle something
like that so
in retrospect i think that what i would
have liked to tell my younger self is
hey
if you're doing something you need to
scale out do it via the process model
have simple
self-contained processes that you can
easily scale up and down
don't try to like re-implement an
operating system like i did just keep
things really simple and you will be
fine
all right next the next factor is all
about disposability
now the rule here is you want to
maximize the robustness
of your applications by having them
start up really quick
shut down really quick and just in
general be really graceful so what do i
mean by this well
here are the rules first rule shut down
gracefully
when a sig term is received so when an
operating system wants to shut down your
process it's going to send you a sig
term
signal and you can catch that signal and
that gives you an opportunity to clean
up the state of your process before you
actually shut it down
now this is really important so if
you're in the middle of building a web
a web a worker process for example where
you're processing items from a queue
you would finish processing the item and
then shut down the next rule
is always shut down within a few seconds
when you don't shut your application
down within a few seconds it causes all
sorts of problems
because the operating system or the
scheduler or whatever is launching these
processes
isn't going to know if your process has
frozen or if it's you know
actually working properly so shut down
quickly um and finally you want to be
robust against sudden death
so when you're designing and
architecting your projects you don't
want to write stuff
such that you know let's say you're in
the middle of processing this item from
a queue
and your your process is just killed
that shouldn't impact your application
negatively
you know another worker should pick up
this this this task and process it
eventually
but you want to be really robust against
sudden death so you don't have a lot of
problems down the road
now the way i screwed this up is also
going to go back to that telephony
conference calling application from
before
so at this point in time i had moved the
application onto the cloud
and i could dynamically scale it kinda
so
the application would load balance
incoming calls and basically you know i
had some processes running to handle
them
and essentially i had just finished
writing my own auto scaling software to
add and remove processes as we just
discussed but the problem i ran into is
when i tested it locally everything
worked
but then when i deployed things into
production i would get problems like
this the process would start
but then after a little while it would
just fail and then just be restarted
over
and over and over again and it took me a
little while to figure out why
and the reason why this didn't work is
because essentially and i'm dumbing this
down a bit but
my startup routine for these processes
looked something like this
the first thing i did when i started up
was i downloaded the audio files
necessary
for these teleconferencing lines to be
served just like i talked about before
so i tried to make them stateless
then after that was done i would bind
myself to the appropriate port
so the load balancer would know that my
application was now online and would
start servicing more requests
and the problem was this download bit
right here and the reason why is
instead of just downloading the audio
files a particular process needed i was
downloading every audio file ever
created which was
hundreds of gigabytes worth and so
basically in the real world when i would
run this stuff
the process would start and then it
would start downloading hundreds of gigs
of files
and because that takes more than 30
seconds the auto scaling software i had
would say well this application hasn't
bound to the port and it's been 30
seconds
it must not be working so we'll just
kill it and then restart it so it would
never finish
and of course in testing i had all the
files set up locally so i didn't have
this issue
but this is a really hard thing to debug
so again keeping this stuff simple and
keeping it stateless
is really important all right next let's
talk about dev prod parity
so the idea here is you always want to
keep all of your development
environments as similar as possible
so development staging production they
should all be identical now this is one
of those rules that i'm ashamed to admit
i break all the time on purpose
i always feel bad about it but i'm just
really lazy and i'll show you what i
mean
so just a couple months ago i was
building this website and the website
was pretty simple it just
wrote some data into a postgres database
nothing fancy
and i was working on it and i thought to
myself well
i just got a new laptop and i want to
work on this project but
i don't really want to install postgres
and like get it all set up
the same way that i have in production
so i'm just going to cheat and use sql
lite
now if you've ever used sql lite it's
like my favorite database of all time
okay it's a sql database
but you don't need a server to run it
it's fantastic it just stores all the
data in a single file
it's really convenient for testing
things out and
so i wrote all my code and tested
against sql lite again both of these are
sql databases they support the same
commands and everything so
technically when i deployed my code into
production on postgres
everything should have worked fine but
what happened instead is i got a bunch
of varchar
errors and the reason why is because
unlike postgres
which sanely checks the length of a
varchar field
uh sqlite does not respect that [ __ ] at
all it's like do whatever the [ __ ] you
want basically
so uh the lesson i learned is even if
things are pretty similar
don't treat them as such like when
you're doing stuff in development try if
you can
to make sure that everything's the same
version everything's the same you know
software it makes your job a lot easier
in the future all right next let's talk
about logs
uh you always want to treat logs as
event streams in 12 factory applications
so what do i mean well
you have an application it generates
some log information
and there's a few rules you should
generally follow rule number one
log should be ordered by timestamp makes
sense
rule number two logs should always be
written to standard out
just a general thing and rule number
three
your application logs should consist of
all of your process and backing service
logs together so what does that mean
well
if you have an application and it has a
postgres database and a worker process
the logs fed application should have the
you know not only the web server code
but also the worker logs
as well as the database logs combined
into some form that you can search
so this story is the most like damaging
one i'm going to reveal to you today
and trust me there are way bigger things
that i've screwed up but this one is
definitely the worst i feel comfortable
sharing on a stage
uh basically that conference calling
application the way it worked
is we were making money every minute
that people stayed on these free
teleconferencing lines
we would make approximately 50 cents per
minute us which is a lot of money
because we had you know thousands of
users using these conference lines all
the time
so the way everything was architected
was something like this
i had a bunch of asterisk servers that
handle all the phone calls
and i had a web app that people could
use to manage their phone their
teleconferencing lines
and i had an api service i wrote which
was sort of the central source of truth
for everything
so when a call came in this conference
call service would receive an api
request from an astra server and it
would say okay
i'm going to log some billable call
details
and all these logs made their way into a
file called calls.csv
on that server now the reason this is
important is because once a month what i
would have to do
is copy that calls.csv file from the
server onto my laptop
and then i would have to do some like
data manipulation then send it to the
phone company and that's how we would
get paid this is like the way we made
our revenue
um and so one day it's about halfway
through the month
and i decided to copy the calls.csv file
onto my laptop
to do some analysis to see how much
money have we generated so far in the
month
where are we at etc and when i did that
i noticed something was a little off the
amount of calls that we had was the
exact same as the prior month
and i was like well that's never
happened that's a mighty big coincidence
and then i had this sinking feeling in
my stomach like i just felt like like if
you
go right down a roller coaster and you
just feel like really sick
and uh and then i slowly had the dread
like
go into my fingertips and i started
hitting up in the shell so i could see
the last command i wrote
and what i did is i'd reverse the
arguments to scp
so instead of copying this file from
here onto my laptop i had copied last
month's file from my laptop
and overrode the logs there which as you
can imagine is a pretty big
mistake so what i did of course is i
went and i said okay
it's not a big deal i'll look at the
logs from here and i'll be able to
reassemble this not a big deal
but in my naivete what i had done is i
said well hey
writing logs is actually pretty slow
like it slows stuff down so i turn them
all off here
now what i should have done of course is
i should have had everything logging
their their stupid ass
logs going into a log route or somewhere
that i could have reassembled this from
but i absolutely did not do that
so i had to make an extremely painful
phone call to my partner and say hey
oh you know we have a little bit of a
problem it was it was a terrible
conversation
and that cost me about half a million
dollars u.s that's
i think 450 000 euros right something
like that
so terrible anyways the final fact we're
going to talk about today
is the the last the 12th one admin
processes all right
so admin processes are tasks that you
need to run
as a one-off thing so let's say you need
to run a database migration you need to
alter something in your database
well when you do that you have some
commands you need to run or some
thing you need to do to like accomplish
this right and what you want to do
ideally
is codify that you know generate a task
like a function that executes from the
cli something like that
check it into your code base and then
after that you want to deploy it to your
production infrastructure
and then in the same way that you would
for example launch a new web process to
scale up
you would launch a admin task process in
production
to run this database migration and i
screwed this up a couple years ago in
like a major way
by doing exactly what i just told you so
what i did is i was working on this new
feature
and i was about to go on and i'm not
exaggerating this at all it's the second
vacation i'd ever taken
and the first vacation was an absolute
nightmare it ended up being terrible
so the second vacation i was about to
take i was doing a road trip from san
francisco down to los angeles so
i was working on this new feature it's
about 3 p.m on friday and i was like i
have to get out of here
like immediately and this feature was
completely coded out everything worked
fine on my laptop
of course and the only thing i needed to
do to make this work
was alter a database table and add a new
column
so i knew that i had to write some
database migration code i did that in
like two seconds and then i thought well
i should deploy it into production and
then run it and everything like that but
that's going to take at least an hour
and a half
like it'll go through all the tests
it'll go through the continuous
deployment pipeline
then i'll have to wait for all the
servers to get the new code and then
issue the stuff
and i thought well i only need to run
this once it's not a big deal i'm just
going to do it
so what i did is i just went ahead and
ran the migration code on my laptop
and everything worked i i got output
saying hey it showed me the sql query
that was ran it said you know successful
in 34 milliseconds or whatever
and i said sweet so i pushed my code to
github which triggered the deploy and i
pieced out of there started driving
so about an hour and a half later just
as long as it takes ironically for that
deployment to happen
uh i get this angry phone call from my
partner and he's basically telling me
hey
uh there's no chance you like broke the
like the entire application is there
and i was like no not at all absolutely
not
uh there's no way like i deployed some
code a while ago but that was a long
time ago
it is 100 fine so
later i log in i stop it at mcdonald's
i'm using their free crappy wi-fi
and what i realize of course is i forgot
to update my environment variables that
this was reading from
so instead of altering my production
database i altered my sql lite
database on my laptop which while i mean
that is
useful it is not exactly what i wanted
so we had millions of user requests
hitting this application per second and
it was causing all sorts of issues
because
they was expecting a database column to
exist that didn't
so you know i trashed the whole thing so
anyways
that sort of covers all the 12 factors
now i realize that this has been sort of
a weird talk
but i want to leave you with one thing
to go home with okay the point of all
this
is you know some people are going to say
all right randall you've been a total
idiot
you've committed all these programming
sins and this is your your problem
and here's what i like to think you know
programming isn't black and white right
like
there's a lot of gray area sometimes
it's okay to code things in production i
mean at least for me
you know sometimes it's okay to like
skip writing a test every now and then
you're not gonna die
usually and so i guess the thing that
i'm trying to say is
i make mistakes all the time and i've
been programming for 19 years
and i'm sure all of you make mistakes
and even john carmack one of the best
developers in the world
i'm sure he makes mistakes all the time
too so especially if you're a new
developer
don't worry so much about making
mistakes just worry about learning some
of the patterns to try to avoid them as
much as you can
so anyways with that i just want to say
thank you very much for having me if you
want to see any more crazy stories like
this i have published some of them
on my website you can also check out
octa's website and
tweet octa if you want we have some
really cool articles and stuff about
cyber security and things
like that um and then the final thing i
just want to say is
i had a lot of stores i couldn't tell up
here because they're way too
embarrassing to too many people
so if you want to hear about it come
talk to me later and thank you very much
we'll see you all at the break